[Music]
foreign
[Music]
inflation and Rising food prices have
worsened the global economy already
devastated by the covert pandemic the
challenging situation has inspired many
people to come together and help each
other cooking and eating together plays
a vital role
welcome to the covid-19 special
in Argentina a legendary soup kitchen
that was founded in 1989 managed to keep
its doors open and stop many from going
hungry a father in Colombia invites the
schoolmates of his son who has a
physical disability to their house so
they can cook together but first we head
to Ghana where former cook Elijah amuado
rescues food and distributes it to
people in need
[Music]
here in the town of offenso and Ghana's
Ashanti region Elijah amuado is
coordinating the repackaging of surplus
food
[Applause]
during the pandemic the chef has been
spending even more time mobilizing his
food for all Africa organization the
non-profit rescue surplus food from all
over the country
the food was going to be destroyed it's
still perfectly good to eat but was
labeled incorrectly in its country of
origin
[Applause]
Pato is going to redistribute it to
people in need
[Music]
when covid-19 hit Adam's work became
even more vital
he expanded his organization and focused
on providing emergency food Aid to
Ghana's most vulnerable people
are there is people lost their jobs and
they are livelihood and that created a
huge need for support especially
supporting the area of nutrition shelter
and then at least medicine football
through a covid-19 emergency
Intervention Program
intervened by providing food and
medicine and livelihood support to
vulnerable people targeting mostly those
affected by the coveted pandemic
the coronavirus pandemic has posed a
serious threat to food Security in Ghana
before the pandemic an estimated 1.2
million people were food insecure
within two years that number had doubled
with no end in sight
inflation and Rising food prices are
making a difficult situation worse
food for all Africa was founded in 2015.
the non-profit is West Africa's first
and largest Food Bank
Ado and his team have made it their
mission to fight hunger and Tackle food
waste
since the start of the pandemic they've
recovered nearly a million euros worth
of food from supermarkets hotels and
Farms
they've helped feed more than half a
million people
today the team is headed to a low-income
Community about 50 kilometers from one
of their warehouses
well
my brother good morning how are you
many families here struggle to access
food
today ato's team is prioritizing elderly
women
they're among those most hard hit by the
pandemic
and today we are considering our mothers
who are 60 years and above and according
to the who
about half of ghanaians are severely or
moderately fully secure which we notice
are among our mothers who are 60 years
and above they are mostly affected so we
want to support them with their food
bags and that can also trigger down to
their children and even their
grandchildren
it's a happy moment for the community
these food donations will make a huge
difference for the recipients
and covert hit it affected me
financially
it was hard to find any food at all to
eat
so these food items will really help us
even amid the worsening economic crisis
Ghana's government has been unable to
provide food relief to the most
vulnerable
people have been left to fend for
themselves
Otto is pleased when the food donations
can put a smile on the faces of people
in need
[Music]
I feel very inspired I feel fulfilled it
makes me see that indeed food banking is
a solution to immediate emergency
intervention in our communities
helping those in need it's work the
former Chef is determined to continue
in the Argentinian Capital Buenos Aires
a soup kitchen with a long history of
feeding some of the city's poorest
families managed to keep its doors open
during lockdowns Against All Odds
but sadly the woman who founded the soup
kitchen lost her battle with the
coronavirus while serving the community
that she was so devoted to
[Music]
Andrea Amando has seven brothers and
sisters her father Carlos Armando is a
builder and Her Mother Gladys araganaras
was a homemaker in 1989 when Argentina
was buffeted by hyperinflation her
parents opened a soup kitchen in their
home despite their own hardships Gladys
The Devout Catholic was in charge she
called it the organized community
oh yeah
um some families here had very little
so they decided to make a popular stew
so there would be something to eat every
day first there were 30 people then 50
and today we provide meals to 135
families
um
during the pandemic the soup kitchen was
able to remain open thanks to the
volunteer work of Gladys and her
neighbor Gloria Sotelo the state helped
with food donations in March 2020 the
official lockdown put many people in the
area out of work
even though gladys's own health was
failing she decided to increase the
number of meals to 150 a day
she wanted to continue no matter what
she wanted to work in her soup kitchen
and support her children as she always
said that's how she was she always
wanted to help
we grew up with that Vision her desire
to be there for others
eventually their children convinced
Gladys and Carlos to start isolating to
protect themselves from the virus they
only went into the dining room on the
way to the bathroom Andrea her brothers
and Gloria took charge of the soup
kitchen but on June 14 2020 Gladys and
her husband were hospitalized with
covid-19
Gladys died a month later since then
Carlos has been running the soup kitchen
on his own
she didn't worry about her own health
What mattered to her more was continuing
her work
she knew people needed her
and it wasn't only my wife many other
people believed the same thing
hey opinion
more than 10 million people in Argentina
rely on soup kitchens many of the cooks
who worked in those kitchens died during
the pandemic that's why Gladys son
Franco took part in a campaign to
declare Cook's Essential workers much
like doctors and nurses
after the campaign Andrea and the other
assistants began to receive half the
minimum wage to keep the soup kitchen
running it was vital recognition for
their work
I was thinking of my family first but
also of all the people from the
neighborhood everything was suddenly
closed and many people had nothing to
eat helping keep a place open that
served meals to people meant a lot to me
for Gloria the soup kitchen was also a
source of Hope
we'll manage me and my children they
give me strength for the future and of
course so do the people who come here to
eat
Elba Carrizo is a street cleaner her 12
children also went to the soup kitchen
now she's here to get food for her four
grandchildren
it's like a little nest for all the
children in the neighborhood for
everyone there was nothing like this
before and now we have a place where we
can eat
Gladys was a wonderful person she was
our Angel our protector
meanwhile the group runs more than a
soup kitchen they also offer a literacy
program for young people and adults and
there's a center that gives free legal
advice named after Gladys
staying in South America a thousand
kilometers from Buenos Aires in Northern
Argentina live the Empire people
the pandemic is of course a threat to
this indigenous population but they're
doing their best to protect themselves
from the virus using their own methods
foreign
ly populated border region between
Argentina Brazil and Paraguay so far no
one here has contracted covid-19 but
they're worried the traditional
medicinal plants they rely on to protect
themselves are becoming ever harder to
find
we use our native plants to treat
respiratory diseases but there aren't so
many around Canal because so much of the
forest here has been felt by loggers
and there have been more and more forest
fires the last few months when the
forest is burning we can't breathe as
well
a covid-19 infection would make it even
worse so of course we're worried
in recent years multinational
corporations have occupied vast areas of
indigenous lands to produce pulp for the
paper industry according to the UN The
Pulp and Paper Industries are among the
world's biggest polluters
thank you supplies of drinking water are
now under threat
the introduction of non-native pine
trees has also increased the risk of
forest fires
the community lives confined within five
hectares and is surrounded by tree
plantations
on top of that the forest fire season is
just around the corner
an outbreak of covid-19 in an indigenous
community that lives surrounded by Pine
forests could be very serious the people
there won't be able to treat themselves
or leave they live really far away from
hospitals and other health care
facilities
Argentina's government says it has
introduced measures to protect the
Empire people
after medical staff and essential
workers indigenous communities were one
of the first groups to be vaccinated
their vaccination rate is 90 to 95
percent
despite efforts to get the vaccines to
isolated areas many members of the
imbaya community did not want to be
vaccinated
they prefer to rely on traditional
medicinal plants and their knowledge of
nature passed down through the
generations
the Earth has belonged to us for
generations and we take care of it
because we can only live and survive
together with nature
as a people we were here long before
anyone else
here hopes to protect itself from the
Coronavirus
lying on Ancient traditions
do you have a question about the
Coronavirus send it in and our science
reporter Derek Williams will draw on the
latest research to answer it
write to us at covert producer dw.com
this week JL wanted to know
does your body Wipe Out the virus
entirely or does some remain in you even
after recovery
some pathogens remain in the body at low
levels more or less permanently after
infecting you and and they can flare up
and cause symptoms even years later
that's the case with viruses in the
herpes family for instance which go
dormant in cells long term by hiding
their genetic material in ours there it
can persist for for long periods and
because the infection isn't active it's
basically invisible to your immune
system but in the right circumstances
like if you're exhausted the viral
genome can be triggered and infected
cells begin churning out virus again
causing for example a cold sores or or
the painful blisters known as shingles
this kind of infection is called a
latent one and although herpes viruses
and some other viruses establish latency
as far as we know SARS cov2 and other
coronaviruses don't work that way but
but that doesn't mean that pockets of
them can't persist in the body for a lot
longer than you might think and they do
in some people especially the
immunocompromised there have been plenty
of cases where researchers continue to
detect SARS Kobe 2's genetic material
for months after an initial infection
long past the time when it should have
been cleared and studies are ongoing
into what that means exactly one thought
is that persistent pockets of
coronavirus in the body might at least
in some people be linked directly or
indirectly to Long covid symptoms
um if even small amounts of virus were
still replicating in an otherwise mostly
cleared patient that could be in theory
enough to activate an immune response
for instance that that might cause
inflammation which in some cases could
lead to problems like like brain fog or
or persistent fatigue the ones that
often afflict long haulers
um but but that theory hasn't been
proven yet and there are other
explanations out there for why even
otherwise healthy people can come down
with the wide range of symptoms that
fall under the umbrella term long covet
foreign
from covid-19 one woman in Berlin has
had her life turned upside down
her day-to-day life is docked by severe
concentration problems and overwhelming
fatigue
nothing is as it was before for our
series my covert we report from Germany
the worst part is the weakness in your
body it's overwhelming after a few
seconds it's so bad that you feel like
you could collapse
you feel like you just have to sit down
and put your feet up it's like the brain
can't keep up anymore I forget things
even something I said just a second ago
or what other people said to me numbers
and names just go
my name is Monica my name is Monica I'm
60 years old and since August I've had
covid-19 symptoms
after about 10 days I tested negative
again and felt great in comparison I
thought everything would be okay I was
active for two days and felt almost 100
better but after the second day I
noticed I'd overdone it in the following
days that feeling of weakness came back
and it's been coming and going ever
since
daily life has become very difficult
especially shopping
going out is very hard for me I now have
a fold-out chair to sit on so I can at
least sit down at the checkout I can't
stand for long periods of time
I have to think about each step I take
what can I manage
how many steps can I handle I have a
small bicycle without pedals so I can at
least move around a little bit
a friend of mine took the pedals off my
bike it's like a bridge to the outside
world for me
it gives me the chance to get out and do
a bit of shopping and complete other
essential tasks
and
because I try to manage my energy so I
can get a little bit of something done
every day
I hope I'll be able to get by with that
long term and still get to experience
the outside world a bit
I'm happy
that I made it
and I feel proud that I can still
accomplish something good
yeah that's later yeah unfortunately
experiencing an 80 or 90 crash is not so
nice
everything becomes very weird
even reading is difficult
letters don't seem to be where they
belong
words appear back to front too when I
look at this text it's not easy to
decipher
I'd prefer not to look at it at all
how can someone forget everything from
one day to the next I don't understand
it at all
writing is really important to me
because I wanted to write to a doctor
who was familiar with the problem can
um
I hope to get help and some
understanding and maybe some tips on
finding myself a doctor who had
experience in this area
the interactions with doctors were quite
difficult for me they were very
unreceptive and even
ignorantly they didn't understand what
my problem was
they thought nothing was wrong with me
my lab results were normal my blood
pressure was good and my pulse was
normal too
everything looked great so they thought
what's her problem
the most important thing for me is
understanding what's happening to my
body what's going on with it what causes
me to feel the way I do now
I've researched a lot but I still can't
really understand it I'm not a doctor so
I don't know I can look up all the terms
on Google but I'd rather have a doctor
who can say to me yes you have this or
that and maybe you can do this or that
to treat it
I probably won't get help since it's an
illness that isn't treatable but maybe
everyday life could be made a bit easier
I'd just like to go out dancing again to
move my body and be around people
to experience new things and meet up
with friends and acquaintances
I'd really like to go to places and see
things again I just want this to go away
that's my greatest wish for it just to
be over
foreign
[Music]
billion people around the world are
living with disabilities the closure of
schools and other facilities made their
lives even more difficult one father in
Colombia whose son needs round-the-clock
here decided to launch a cooking based
Therapy Group at his house
Rubio Fernandez's life changed with the
arrival of his youngest child he quit
his police job and devoted himself to
Francisco who needs round-the-clock care
when the pandemic started the two found
themselves cut off from the outside
world
but then rubia Fernandez had an idea
here in my kitchen in my house I started
offering cooking classes for people with
disabilities this is where the magical
project was born the cooking Adventure
we have for children with disabilities
after the lockdown was lifted the
therapy kitchen project found a new and
larger home in the sensory Life Center
trained therapists and caregivers could
now join in
the children were super motivated but
the kitchen of Mr Fernandez was too
small for the entire group so the
decision was made to move it here we
started with a dessert project and that
worked out beautifully
the therapists and caregivers at the
center say that therapy kitchen is
helping their patients put the lockdown
behind them
learning to cook brings them both
physical and emotional benefits
they make lots of progress they get out
of their routine and feel like an active
part of the community
often they feel they're not good at
anything but here they can do things for
themselves
Daisy Mora is also benefiting
she's visually impaired and lost her job
during the pandemic her therapist
recommended joining the cooking therapy
to help lift her spirits
it's hard to find a job around here and
with a disability it's twice as hard but
then it got worse the first people they
let go were the ones who shouldn't have
been thrown out as their most vulnerable
Daisy Mora uses the classes to learn new
recipes and cooking techniques
it's also helped her get back on her
feet after the lockdown
we don't want to be pitied we're just
like everyone else we may do things
differently but we're the same human
beings with the same rights but with
different abilities
the classes are free of charge for
participants
rubia Fernandez volunteers here part of
his police pension goes toward buying
ingredients
the dishes they prepare are sold at
local markets
the income then helps maintain the
kitchen
for rubier the therapy kitchen has given
him a new vocation
foreign
his father's love and the affection of
the other participants
foreign
that's all for this episode of the
covid-19 special see you again next week
till then stay healthy
[Music]